gipfeltreffen der ausgezeichneten herres
sportlerinnen und heeressportler am
samstag beim tag des sports 20 21 rund
um das wiener ernst happel stadion zu
dem bereits erreichten spitzenplätzen
und medaillen gibt es heute für einige
noch eine auszeichnung zusätzlich
nämlich die für die sportlerinnen und
die sportler des jahres in den
unterschiedlichsten kategorien
überreicht diesmal vom generalsekretär
des bundesheeres dieter kantel
[Musik]
gemacht und ich bin ganz ganz stolz auf
unsere sportlerinnen und sportler
sportlerin des jahres wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
den sportler des jahres wird diskus-ass
und bronze gewinner lukas weißhaidinger
besser kann das jahr 20 21 für ihn
bisher gar nicht sein
schöne veranstaltung hat aber wirklich
viel fenster sowohl autogramme verteilen
kann
fotos morgens etwas machen wir doch
sagen barrieren kriegt dann ist es
richtig cool
[Musik]
die meisten sportlerinnen und sportler
nutzen den tag auch zum austausch
untereinander worüber man das und
spricht es gekommen weil sie unter uns
sportlern schon nach kapitel über
training ein bisschen über die
gesamtgestaltung wie man große erfolge
fort es ist sensationell weil einfach
quer durch die palette von wintersport
über sommersport paralympische sport
eigentlich alles dabei ist man quasi
extrem gut austauschen heute mal
hauptthema ist der sport natürlich aber
manchmal die meisten jetzt im urlaub war
ja wie die
planungen die wir nach dem spiel gemacht
haben die ferien
damit auch in zukunft wieder
stockerlplätze und medaillen möglich
sind und heute nun ausgezeichnet oder
nicht eines zeichnet die große familie
der heeres sportlerinnen und harris
sportler ohnehin bereits aus körper und
geist in einklang zu haben und dort auch
die fitness an den tag zu legen das
zeigen unsere sportlerinnen und sportler
ganz besonders und dafür werden sie sind
sie heute einige ganz besonders dann
gelobt werden
[Musik]